we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p very
interested to hear that the former
governor of California arnold
schwarzenegger actually called in and he
had a he had a message he had he had a
whole agenda he wanted to espouse to our
audience take a listen
David this is arnold schwarzenegger
calling i was watching your show and I
saw you told the story about being on
the airplane and the little baby in the
seat behind you giving you a hard time
and kicking the seats and how you turned
around when you did this I saw the eye
roll let me tell you you need to watch
my movie Kindergarten Cop right in
Kindergarten Cop the little boy with
kicking my seat so I jumped around to
him and I took a pencil and I said hey
if you don't quit screwing around back
there this is what I'm going to do you
got a pencil in half that's what you
need to do don't be such a girly man and
they went off your show you guys are
great say hi to pass for me right okay
bye are you surprised to hear because I
don't think Arnold is an advocate of the
vegan lifestyle is it surprising to you
that he has come out so forcefully in
favor of producer Pat um yeah I did I
didn't know that yeah a big fan of the
vegan lifestyle well I don't think he
lives it let me put it that way where do
we even go with this yeah it's hard for
me to imagine
Arnold flying economy that's one thing
have you seen Kindergarten Cop I've
never seen it I mean it doesn't seem
like it's that hard to break a pencil in
half like I can do that now you have the
strength of Arnold Schwarzenegger right
after all you are a SOI boy as the many
in the audience have told us and now I'm
a SOI boy as well basically that's the
new insult by association apparel yeah
okay we've got a great bonus show for
you today a lot of great stories one
including a circumcision which is a
hot-button topic all the time on the
program we will talk about airport bins
to toss out marijuana and lots of other
stuff but this is all on the bonus show
and in order to hear these stories
you've got to get access to the bonus
show which you can do one of two ways
number one become a member at david
pakman.com slash membership number two
become a patron for at least five bucks
a month at patreon.com slash david
pakman show and lastly get your day
Pakman show coffee mugs now available
for coffe Effie green tea espresso
whatever you want to put in this thing
I'm fine with get it at david pakman.com
slash gear and check out all of our
other great stuff bumper stickers
hoodies hatred mail t-shirts etc etc oh
I'm not supposed to say etc the audience
has asked that I never say etc pronounce
that correctly at least I did this time
yeah all right talk to you on the bonus
show